thanks to you guys for coming to see the
talk yeah so I'm Irene II I'm a data
scientist a Goose's I've been there for
three years now and I'm gonna be talking
to you about where we are with
recommendations how we got there and
where we hope to go yeah I hope hope you
enjoy it so first of all just a quick
show of hands who's actually heard of
goo stove before oh wow
it's like the first time we started
talking this is such a difference oh
that's really cool for those of you who
haven't heard of us we are a meal kit
delivery company so basically you come
to our website we have a weekly menu of
40 recipes do you pick which recipes you
want what day you want it delivered on
and on that day we send you a box with
pre-portion ingredients and step by step
recipe cards so you know we get to do
all the boring planning and shopping and
you get to do all the fun cooking and
meeting and hopefully with well with
virtually zero waste it was kind of
win-win so we've since we started we've
like really pushed to improve our
customer proposition so from having 12
recipes on the many a week we've gone up
to 40 from three days delivery we've
gone up to like seven day delivery and
from all this by keeping like a
relatively low low price so a lot of the
way we we manage this is through data
science so I just wanted to give you a
little bit of a flavor of the different
ways in which we actually use data
science augusto so this is a kind of
typical customer journey so someone will
you know see us on an ad come to our
website and pick recipes so even in that
journey so we've got segmentation making
sure that you know we're understanding
kind of where you know why our customers
are coming to us and then once you've
picked your recipes it will be all
packed
in one of well in our delivery center up
in Lincolnshire so for that for example
we have forecasting with that short lead
time it's really important for us to be
able to tell our suppliers how much of
each ingredient we're going to need
quite early on so we've really you know
invested in building a robust
forecasting algorithm to make sure that
that we can give customers what they
want but also that we as a business are
making sure we're keeping our food waste
low and that you know we're being
sustainable so that's quite a big part
of it then warehouse operation so in our
warehouse we also heavily rely on data
science so we've got different
optimization algorithms to make sure
that all the ingredients are kind of
where they should be and the boxes are
being routed in a way that is going to
have the most throughput so that we can
pack the maximum amount of boxes and the
least amount of time and hopefully
you'll get the box you'll really enjoy
it and you'll come back but if you don't
we are keeping a watchful eye and so
we've also built a churn model algorithm
so from really early on we take all the
user behavior data and we can kind of
start seeing if we think you're gonna
leave us hopefully we can change your
mind and then kind of tying it together
and it touches quite a lot of places is
personalization and recommendations
which is what I'm going to talk to you
about today so before we go into a bit
more technical stuff I just wanted to
you know I think it's always useful to
give a little bit of context of why why
we're doing this so why did we think
that recommendations was something we
wanted to go after augusto so as I said
we always knew they liked we wanted to
improve our proposition and increase the
number of recipes and we're at 40 now
but we're not necessarily stopping that
so it's really important that we give
people a way to comfortably navigate
that amount of choice we don't want it
to become kind of paralyzing and we want
to make sure that people are able to
find choice that is relevant to them and
that is meaningful
then also discovery we want gusto to be
exciting we don't want it to you know be
giving you the same recipes all the time
we want to entice you to try new things
try new cuisines make sure that we've
got like you know a good amount of
different stuff so discovery is also one
of like our big things finally
convenience like gusto we like to think
and we try to make it as convenient as
service as possible you know hopefully
it's it's helping you with your with
your week so we want to make sure that
we also translate that to the menu so we
want it to even though we have a lot of
choice make it super hard so in the
opposite super easy and quick for you to
to find those those recipes so we
thought we could tackle these three
things through recommendations and allow
us to expand our proposition while
keeping these three things in mind so
when we decided this we just kind of
went ahead launch into and we did quite
a lot of research online and we actually
found light of em so if you've heard of
life em it is a a package done from
match a at list when he used to be at
least and it's a matrix factorization
package and it does you know quite a lot
of things like really well so we found a
lot of successful examples of people
using it online and it allows you to put
you know like metadata for a lot of
things so we like right let's let's go
for it we tried to implement it and
actually we were really struggling to
get like consistent results so we were
seeing that our metrics like were not
really very good they were changing a
lot from many to menu so we started you
know forking and trying to tweak it a
little bit and again we spoke to like
the author and he's super helpful but
ultimately it was quite computationally
heavy and I think because we were at the
beginning of our journey we were still
trying to speak to stakeholders and
stuff it was also quite hard to explain
to them it was quite black boxy so we
kind of got almost to the end of the
road with this and sat down and said
okay wait
let's let's maybe take a step back and
think okay why is this really good for
like a lot of other stuff but isn't
working in our case so we thought and we
had a big session and we thought okay so
what is actually kind of what makes our
problem different number one we have a
lot of new recipes so obviously you know
it's a said diversity and convenience
like we want to make sure we're giving
customers its new recipe so about 20 to
25 percent of a menu is consisted of me
recipes so we need to make sure that the
cold start problem so if you're not
familiar with the cold start problem
it's a fact that you sometimes struggle
to recommend either new items or for any
users because you don't have any data on
them to go about so we need to make sure
that we had a really strong solution
against this because otherwise that was
really going to affect our metrics too
it's apparently we have a changing menu
so so I've said we have 42 recipes on
the menu and they change week by week
some of them say the same but basically
they're they're different week by week
which means that we only have like a
tiny portion of our catalog available at
any one time which is again quite
different to many other use cases and
number three is the fact that we have a
weekly meal plan so a you can only buy a
certain amount of portions per box
anyway which is kind of inherently
creating constraints there but number
two is the fact that you know if you are
preparing for your week and you want to
make sure that you've got variety within
that week so if you really like wraps
chances are you even if there are three
on the menu you're not gonna buy three
rats you're going to want a mixture so
it's not enough with pushing to the top
the stuff that we think you're really
going to like and so going back to this
we said okay let's keep it simple what
do we really know about and that's our
recipes we have a lot of information on
our recipes and we thought that you know
some of those things would be really
fixed by understanding a what is a
recipe B what is how do you define
recipe similarity
turns out it's actually super hard so we
we kind of got a team of people together
and we all kind of discussed different
you know it's from the whole business it
was the food team it was a digital
product team we all kind of started
brainstorming okay what do we think is
important about a recipe what defines it
and we came up with like a really yeah
long list of attributes that obviously
we know so we started like populating
that and then yeah in terms of recipe
similarity so it really means different
things to different people and I think
that's like super you know it's become
super clear to me over time so just a
quick example I hope well really got
like two hostile lunch
they've got Brazilian black beans and
limey chicken with rice and then a
Cambodian chicken sound like hurry so
for someone who comes to our website
because unused is our service because
you know they're perhaps a bit stuck in
a rut and want to try like you know
really exciting different flavors
they're like all once Brazilian ones
Cambodian you know they're really
different in flavor yeah I can totally
lease to you in a week no problem but
for someone else who perhaps uses our
service and make sure that they're
eating a balanced diet they're like well
yeah it's different flavor but actually
it's just chicken and rice so I wouldn't
want to have it in the same in the same
box and that's just you know a tiny
example but but like if you talk to
different people about this even within
the office people just have such
different ways of of approaching this so
yeah so with our taxonomy that we
created that I had discussed what we
actually decided to do was to upload it
to a graph database called the air for J
so when a graph database it's just a
different way of storing of storing data
so you saw everything in kind of
relationship so you say you know
spaghetti bolognaise has ingredient
tomato paste and what this allowed us to
do is to really work to really easily
have a look at what what features
certain recipes shared in which they
didn't share so in this example you know
we can both see that
these two pastas have dished out pasta
but you can see that one has lamb one
has pork so yeah this is like we started
building this this graph database and I
wanted to touch like really quickly on
why we decided to go for neo4j for this
case so if you can imagine a recipe and
ingredient data's or like super
connected it's all like a bit you know
messy and that's what we were really
interested on for this problem to solve
recipe similarity it was we wanted a way
to quickly analyze those connections
number two is it gives like a really
nice flexible data structuring so say
you know for example for tuna we want to
give it the attribute tint but we don't
care that something else isn't in so we
it's really easy to just give it to
certain ingredients and not to others
and thirdly it's really easy to create
inferences so we can say okay if a
recipe has ingredient chili flakes then
we can very easily give it the attribute
spicy and it's really easy to connect to
to Python and to learn cipher which is
their query language so yeah this is a
little bit of why we chose to to go down
this route and also this is just like a
really quick aside so please don't ask
me any questions on this because it was
a super quick like side project that
some of my team did so yes we know that
there's a lot of properties to describe
our recipes but actually the way we
choose the way people choose on our menu
and our menu in general is incredibly
visual you might have two recipes that
actually are very similar in terms of
takes profiles or whatever but if
they're displayed you know maybe a
better of needles are a better fries and
a fish fill it on top they can look
incredibly similar and it might look
like you know it it's a big part of it
so we did a bit of work to build an
autoencoder this is where we slash they
got to to really try and put down to
similarity but that was just a little
aside to show you you know but even
though we've got a lot of data there's
also always so much more
to consider so yeah this is kind of the
basis of our content-based recommender
so taking what we have in the graph
database we use different similarity
metrics and we ended up landing on
jacquard we found it gave us the best
you know the best metrics which is
incredibly simple and great so once we
had like a similarity metric between any
two given recipes we kind of aggregated
that with the customers order history
and that gave us a really easy way to
rank for the recipes on the menu we're
recommending for to rank from top to
bottom in terms of how similar is it to
stuff that we know you've already bought
so super simple this was kind of a first
version that went live and we actually
saw really positive results like
compared to random even though we didn't
tell them we were ranking the recipes
like Louis more people were ordering
from those top ranks so you know we're
really excited that they we'd you know
done our first step so good points for
content-based it deals really well with
a cold start problem for any recipes
that I was describing earlier because we
know the information about those recipes
as well as old recipes so that's really
good points for it however we ran into
what is known in the office as the
chicken conundrum
so me personally I order maybe three
recipes least a week one of them is
normally always chicken and then I have
you know maybe a beef one week maybe a
fish one week and it varies but if you
look at all my data like about 30% of
our recipes are chicken now because you
can see this is like pretty simple is a
really rule-based approach which means
that what's the recommendation and
you're going to recommend me chicken so
this is an example they're basically all
chicken and so
yeah and we tell her the stuff I promise
so yeah this is kind of we realized that
this is this was a big problem of
content-based even though we've done a
step forward there was the big problem
that our recommendations just lacked
variety so we needed to to address that
somehow so again in the same way that we
tried to approach the content base from
a simple way we said okay how can we
approach this variety in alternate
simple way and so this we decided to
start yet using a very simple
collaborative base so for those four you
don't know collaborative is you know
because use a user like you ordered X so
you will also like X so again I'm going
back to super basics what we did was
create features for all of our users so
based on what they were ordering a
little bit of behavioral data we used
some k-means clustering and found kind
of well yeah these five clusters so we
had a look at them to make sure that
they were giving something you know
generally reasonable and you could I
mean this is like super simplifying it
but more or less we can see that the
clusters made sense there was you know
more vegetarian slightly more
pescetarian certainly more Asian flavors
so this made sense to us and what we did
was then say okay so for each of the
clusters of all the old recipes that
have already been on the menu what what
did they over index on what did this
cluster by more than than anyone else
and obviously as you can imagine for the
pescetarian it will you know tend to be
biscuit arrow recipes so yeah this kind
of gave us five different rankings for
each of one for each of the cluster and
each user will be assigned to one of the
different to one of the different
clusters so yeah so as I mentioned again
this doesn't deal with the cold start
problem because we we don't know how
people you know those recipes haven't
been on the menu so we can transfer for
old recipes for new recipes sorry but
it's don't really well with the old ones
and then when we had our previous
ranking and this new ranking we worked
on how to combine both to them so used
board account which is used Wikipedia
tell some weird Slovenian districts to
decide the politician already sure so
yeah what we have here is like examples
of recipes our first method route so all
of them are ranked because it doesn't
have the cold start problem and the way
board account works is you basically
give each each ranking a score which is
just simply the rank divided by how many
recipes there are so that's our
content-based rank then we have a
collaborative rank so as you can see the
new recipes don't have a rank for this
because as we said we can't do that with
with this method and then again we had
to think okay so what's how do we
balance the fact that like we don't have
ranks for new recipes with a
collaborative score and give it in the
new rank so we created an extra ranking
which is the the content rank but only
for the new ones to to make it a little
bit fairer on those new recipes as well
and then you simply add the score and as
you can see so the biggest change is
kind of you know the beef recipe beef
recipe which you know is fourth in the
content rank would actually was at the
bottom of the collaborative rank and
ends up at the bottom overall so we have
moved the things that were a little bit
more extreme which is what we wanted so
we don't want to get fully go away from
that content based recommendations
because we know it's tough you're gonna
want but we do want to you know spice
things up a little bit with the
collaborative things idea before I move
on when we were going when we were
validating this we actually found that
our metric so our basket match on past
many's went down from what we had which
if if you think about it again thinking
about the chicken like if we give you a
chicken we know we're gonna get it right
kind of thing
at least once but you know we hadn't
think inside okay well even though I'm
metric might go down a little bit it's
what's best for the customer right we
don't want to keep showing them at the
expense of this metric and then we can
focus on improving it in different ways
yeah that's that and then I just really
briefly wanted to touch on how
everything's structured so we run
everything through air flow which used
to be like an air B&B open source tool I
think it's not a B&B now but but yeah
it's an orchestration tool so we can
tell everything we've got everything
running a schedule our recommendation
engine we're running it on docker and on
AWS batch so it collects data from neo4j
as I discussed before so it retrieves
that taxonomy data and it also speaks to
our data Lake which is based on a lot of
stuff that my date and how to engineer
will be you know we'll know more about
and I know that we fetch data from there
and we also make sure to put it back so
that the rest of our services can can
use it so yeah just just to let you know
so that's where we are now but obviously
we have a lot of ideas for the future so
first of all I think as you can see our
collaborative version it's just five
rankings so we do want to make sure that
we is again a good first step but let's
start building on it and we've come
across neural collaborative filtering
which I think is going to be our next
step to make sure that we're really
paralyzing that collaborative aspect as
well a little bit more then something
else we want to start touching upon is
feedback introduction so either
implicit so we're starting to say okay
if we know you haven't ordered from like
the top ranks like let's take that into
account and down wait there's recipes a
little bit and like really reward
recipes from like perhaps the bottom
that you've picked to make sure that
we're keeping that right but also we
want to start using explicit feedback so
giving customers you know like it
Spotify or whatever to say like yes or
no in terms of of recommendations so
we're really excited about that and then
at the moment we run it once a week so
with with the current setup we don't
need to run it anymore because it's not
really gonna give us much better results
but we do wanna start to move towards
like slightly more dynamic approach so
can we make
collaborative in a way where actually we
can use the data that's happening live
to feed into like you know people have
an ordered yet and also even make it
even more dynamic if we know what you've
put in a basket at your first recipe can
we tell you all we think you'll enjoy
this as with it and start suggesting
things like that so yeah lots to come
hopefully soon and then I just wanted to
finish off with a bit less technical
stuff but we found that like you might
have you know you can have a good
algorithm and even just by ranking the
recipes we've saw good results but where
we've really seen like a significant
difference in conversion and in other
metrics it's through tying that to the
UI and UX so you think it's really
important and we've been working quite
hard on getting people to to understand
a little bit more of why we're doing
what we're doing and surfacing those
recommendations in a more obvious way so
so now when they you know reach the
point where they can get recommendations
they'll get an an email and be like hey
you're in this is great we've built a
just for you collection where we show
like the top 25 recipes instead of 40 so
yeah and we tell them about it and all
this is like really helping us see make
those those big those big differences so
don't underestimate the importance of
you a UI and UX and as well for example
you can see this is only nine recipe
so for people with really clear dietary
preferences we've been like cut making
the short list like you know
dramatically just to show them what they
want so even there they could go to a
vegetarian collection just by showing it
there at the beginning just what they
want we've seen like really significant
improvements in conversion which tells
us that hopefully if we manage to do
that well for everyone
there'll be big rewards and you know
just to let you to finish off with what
I started at first so again hopefully
you can see how we address relevant
choice through the content base by
giving people what they really want we
addressed discovery through our
collaborative filtering and then we're
addressing convenience through that
smart many reduction making sure that
people can find what they want quickly
so just to finish till always like kind
of three key learnings I think with what
we've learnt along the way it's number
one before you jump into anything like I
think really stop and understand why
your problem is different I think it
saves a lot of time and just makes you
when you're looking for a solution you
already like thinking about that so
really make sure you understand what
makes your problem unique start with
what you know like I think it was really
good for us like we knew we had all this
data on recipes that was ours we didn't
have to you know rely on anything else
and and I guess like don't be scared of
doing something super simple like
sometimes simple things working and
there's nothing wrong with that like
content-based ISM very hard and it's
given us really good results and then
finally yeah convenience is more
important than accuracy like I think as
a scientist is it's quite easy till I
get you know really you know bogged down
with the metrics and be like ah we've
moved this by like you know a tiny bit
but actually less you know I think you
need to think about how does this affect
your customer because your customer
doesn't care about your tiny uplift in
the o metric but they might really care
about you know other kinds of things so
make sure that you're keeping that in
mind Wow yeah I think that's it
thank you for listening if you want to
follow us at you
ootek and we've got a medium blog to you
know keep up to date with all their
hopefully exciting things that we do
yeah thank you very much
[Applause]
wait so you mean using filters right
right yes I guess the issue of filter um
so yeah I mean I think this so much that
defines the recipe that it's like quite
tough to to work with that and again
like things are so different for
different people that it's really hard
to find the right balance of what you
show and also we think like a lot of
stuff you know you might say odd don't
show me spicy things but actually in the
format we serve it it's really easy to
just not add the chilli flakes so again
or save a lot of stuff so it's it's
thinking about what what you want to
what you want them to like think about
and what you're trying to always give
them a solution for it so we can chat
later a bit more if you want sorry
that's a bit
okay so the question is with if at the
beginning when we didn't have enough
customers how did we deal with warehouse
optimization yeah I mean we've come a
long way
like we definitely went this far I find
years ago we've grown massively so we've
had to to adapt to that so stuff used to
be a lot a lot less optimized but we
always knew that we wanted to grow with
this and minders died working on it soon
so the question is did we ask users if
you know what they wanted for
recommendations and for the recipe
development no we we didn't so this is
all based on what they I mean why not
yet yeah so we're kind of toying with
the idea of you know perhaps having some
kind of dietary preferences and stuff
like this but as I said before it's we
don't want to make it super rule-based
and super you know you've told us you
don't want this so we're definitely not
going to show you this so yeah it's it's
it's a balance
we'll see so what sort of behavioral
features we use for segmentation
so we did not use a lot we mainly
focused on yeah what they were all doing
but we we used like session length and
things like that and how many times they
like swapped you know recipes in and out
to kind of determine if they were more
convenient you know they wanted like a
speedy they just came on the web someone
like boom boom boom or whether they
really thought about things a little bit
more
yeah so in terms of weekly plan do we
take any like time concentration so we
don't at the moment and it is something
that I think we'd really benefit from
and we know it's like I think when we
introduce something like that whether
it's more yeah in that way or more
dynamic like I said like kind of trying
to suggest stuff after you've added to
the basket I think will represent kind
of a next step change because it is a
really hard problem because yeah the
first thing you pick kind of almost
determines everything else and it's
getting that right that can you know
make a week or break a week how long you
trace that the effect of your the effect
of your recommendation for the
evaluation of the metric so we we just
take it as like whatever I so I did we
don't see when well we don't currently
take into account when they ordered it
but yeah I mean that's a really good
point like we should look at if you
order something first then take that
into account magic yeah that's a really
good point hi and how many metrics how
many metrics Oh like you said like a
this so many things in property that are
we we've got a lot I mean a lot hello
you know you know thousands every time a
new recipe comes in yesterday yeah so my
yeah the food developer team kind of
hates me a little bit because I keep
putting them but we obviously we use it
in other parts of the business as well
but but yeah there's a lot of things
that are obviously important from an
operational point of view but then
there's other stuff that is purely you
know more important to kind of me and
someone came up the other day with like
ha but I love
Chii recipes that's what I always do is
like oh god do I have to add something I
was like crunchy now I'll stick around
if you'll yeah I'll be around all day
thanks for the talk I was wondering if
there's any move to use your
recommendation system in terms of how
you build decide on new recipes that
you're adding to your menu and and like
how you go whether you can go from the
sort of content based method you
describe to something sort of generative
where you say this is the kind of recipe
we want yeah so around building new
recipes from what the data we have it's
always been something we've discussed
and I think we are kind of moving to a
place where we have the capacity to be
suggesting that kind of thing and also
yeah just helping more in the general
mini planning side of the business and
yeah me saying okay we've got leiserson
with the recipes here but actually these
ones perform really well but we have
less off can we make sure we introduced
out so we're not doing it yet but it's
definitely something we've discussed and
it's just and I think we'll probably cut
but there is always again that like you
can give